Québec s'apprête aussi à honorer
la mémoire de Joyce Echaquan en
baptisant un lieu en son nom.
Mais bâtir des ponts n'est pas
toujours simple.
Valérie Gamache.
- Il y a un éveil qui s'est
fait, puis... il y a tout
l'après Joyce, tu sais.
Je pense qu'on est encore dans
la plaie qu'il faut nettoyer.
- Il y a comme quelque chose de
vide en dedans de moi, dans le:
on fait quoi maintenant? Comment
on fait quoi dans le concret là?
Je rentre travailler, je fais
quoi pour que ça aille mieux?
- Elles vivent à des kilomètres
l'une de l'autre. Pourtant,
Jolianne et Mélanie font le même
constat: la mort de Joyce
Echaquan les a transformées
en tant qu'infirmières.
- Les intentions sont belles
mais comment le faire
concrètement?
C'est pas si simple.
- À Joliette, le malaise qui
s'est installé persiste.
MÉLANIE PERREAULT, infirmière,
Hôpital de Joliette
- On a peur de faire un faux-
pas, peur de dire un mot de
travers, pour pas se faire
reprocher des choses, mais
aussi pour pas les blesser.
- À Manawan, les Atikamekw sont
plus conscients de leurs droits
croit Jolianne qui ressent de
son côté le devoir de les
défendre.
JOLIANNE OTTAWA, infirmière,
Centre de santé de Manawan
- Ce que j'ai pris... pas
conscience, bien conscience,
c'est beaucoup d'être...
Le rôle d'advocacy.
Je l'avais, tu sais, j'ai
toujours défendu, mais là c'est
passé à un autre step, il y a
des choses qui ne passent plus.
- Mais encore aujourd'hui,
elle n'arrive pas à rassurer les
membres de sa communauté qui
ont peur de se rendre à
l'hôpital de Joliette.
- Mais c'est sûr qu'ils ont des
craintes puis c'est sûr
qu'il y en a qui ne veulent
plus y aller.
- Il y a pourtant eu des
rapprochements avec la
communauté de Manawan. Il y a eu
des formations obligatoires pour
le personnel de l'hôpital
de Joliette. Des formations de
4 heures basées essentiellement
sur l'histoire des
Premières Nations.
- Je me dis : bien si ça a un
peu ouvert les esprits à avoir
plus de compassion, à comprendre
un peu mieux des fois des
comportements, bien je me dis,
je pense qu'on aura gagné.
Je veux croire ça.
- C'est l'individu parce que
même si tu avais... tu pourrais
avoir les meilleures formations,
si t'as pas cette envie-là,
t'as le mépris ou on t'a
toujours dit que des Indiens
c'est sale, c'est des sauvages,
des profiteurs... tu sais...
Je veux dire, ça va rester là.
- Et c'est au tour de Mélanie
d'apprendre à vivre avec
les préjugés.
- Joliette, c'est stigmatisé
en ce moment, on fait qu'a peur,
c'est quasiment gênant de
travailler à Joliette.
- Bienvenue dans le club parce
que nous, on l'a été pendant
des lunes et des lunes, puis
on l'est encore, tu sais.
J'ai beaucoup de compassion
envers les infirmières qui
travaillent à l'hôpital.
Parce qu'effectivement, elles
sont stigmatisées dans le reste
du Québec puis elles sont
à travers le Canada puis
probablement à travers le monde,
ils savent qu'il existe un
hôpital à Joliette où il y a
une Autochtone qui est décédée
là dans des conditions atroces,
tu sais.
IAN LAFRENIÈRE, min. responsable
des Affaires autochtones, Québec
- On a mis une image sur cette
réalité-là qui nous était
rapportée, puis là on l'avait
avec des images, c'était clair.
- Le ministre croit que la mort
de Joyce Echaquan a au l'effet
d'un électrochoc pour les
Québécois. Mais il n'est
toujours pas question d'en
parler comme d'une victime
de racisme systémique.
- Dès que je sors le mot racisme
systémique, les gens se campent
dans leur position complètement.
Je réussis pas à passer
mon message pantoute.
Je vois que les gens veulent,
je veux garder le momentum le
plus longtemps possible.
- Et pour conserver la mémoire
de Joyce, à la demande de sa
famille, le gouvernement lui
dédiera un endroit près
de Manawan.
- Une réserve de biodiversité
qui porterait le nom de Joyce
Echaquan, mais notre intention
c'est de le faire avec la
famille au moment qui est
opportun.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Mélanie et Jolianne craignent
malgré tout que le drame de
Joyce Echaquan tombe
dans l'oubli.
- Ce qu'il faut juste espérer
c'est que ce soit pas juste de
la poudre aux yeux, pas juste
montrer aux gens qu'on a compris
puis, tu sais, ça servira
à rien.
- Faut pas qu'elle soit décédée
juste pour faire une... puis
après ça, on n'en parle plus tu
sais, non, faut vraiment qu'il y
ait quelque chose qui se fasse
puis que ça perdure dans
le temps.
- Ici Valérie Gamache,
Radio